[Applause]
it's rare indeed that these two world
famous men could be brought together in
a film
dr joslin died in 1962 at the age of 93
but fortunately dr best who with dr
banting discovered insulin is still with
us
when one realizes that there are some
one and one half million diabetics in
the united states and another like
amount yet undiscovered
or when at any time you or a member of
your family can be afflicted with this
disease
then and then only can one comprehend
the full value of the contributions of
dr joslin who devoted a lifetime
perfecting the treatment of diabetes
and of dr best
the co-discoverer of life-giving insulin
when you boys know dr best
dr charles best who's coming here today
is the famous doctor who was the
co-discoverer with sir frederick banning
of insulin 40 years ago he's coming here
to take part and to speak
at the elliot p dawson memorial in
oxford
he was a friend of dr johnson's for many
years
dr jocelyn was my doctor he was great
i don't know
you knew he was an old man and yet
somehow he wasn't like a lot of other
old people
well he was 93 when he died
yes
but he
he was always asking questions about our
diabetes
why he even visited us here at camp just
the summer before
[Music]
[Applause]
dr gorman
i know that you and i agree on the
tremendous importance of teaching these
boys good control of their diabetes
as a matter of fact you should set them
a pretty good example i think you've
had diabetes yourself
well
there are three things dr best
first the very close care that my mother
gave me when i was a child
and second the almost imperceptible
transfer
of uh responsibility during my
adolescence
and finally factor common at all times
was the close association and friendship
with my physician
dr best i'd like to have you meet one of
dr josten's former patients scott
currier
scott how did you happen to come to this
camp
dr white she's at the clinic too she
suggested to my folks
dr jocelyn always used to tell me how
important it was to take care of my own
diabetes
he told everyone that that's one reason
he started the camp to teach diabetics
how to take care of themselves
we've had a wonderful group of patients
to honor those who would live longer
with the diabetes
than they were expected to live if they
didn't have it
miss amelia peabody made a life
expectancy medal
this was given
and now we even took two or three
thousand patients and they have
cherished it
because it just showed uh how faithfully
they live
but see so many of them obtained it that
later
we had another medal for patients
and this was given to those who after 25
years of the disease
had perfect blood vessels perfect
eyesight
and a perfect kidneys and were
generally sound in the health
of these we have had now some 98
patients
not one
who has obtained this metal of
perfection
ever was able or
obtained it unless he had followed
treatment
meticulously just as lonnie and alan
prescribed god what do you mean when you
say
take care of yourself
well i think i could show you better
come on over to the clinic and we'll
show you
hey tell stevie to come here a minute
steve is the youngest boy in camp who
takes his own insulin injection dr best
he's only seven and already he's learned
to take care of himself this way okay
hey steve how about giving doctor best
of performance
[Music]
well that's that's me and i have to go
and eat
he's a cute kid but boy he can be a pill
now we'll never hear the end of it i
shot myself for dr best
years ago when doctors didn't know what
they know now
the kids just didn't get very tall sure
i know that they used to call them
diabetic dwarfs it was because they
didn't get enough protein in their diet
now we know we must take care of our
height our weight as well as our diet
you mean that you
weigh and
measure your food and know how to
prepare it here let me show you in the
diet kitchen
i have a diet of so much fat protein and
carbohydrate and i use one of these
scales to measure it
i check myself about once a week now but
i've been doing it for so long i think
my estimates are perfectly all right at
least the doctor and the dietitian think
so
do you find scott that it
takes a lot of time to weigh your food
and take your insulin shots do you find
it hard to do
well at first it was sort of a hard
thing
and then i became used to it and now
it's nothing at all
it's really not even as hot as seventh
grade math
hi betty i was just showing dr best how
we weigh and measure our food the kind
of thing that dr joslin used to teach us
he was always interested in the children
knowing how to do these things
howie where's beedle well i think he's
down by the lake
well when you see him would you give
this to him
wow sure
this is this is for beetle dogs these
bugs about bugs
you know this camp is for fun too
we do everything they do at any camp you
don't have to feel you're sitting on a
bench if you're diabetic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know boys all this activity around
the camp makes me think of another one
of dr johnson's great interest
he was
always trying to find out the influence
of exercise on diabetes
now bushida found this
and this uh puzzled him and embarrassed
him
he found that the patients to whom he
gave a diet
the same diet that he had in the
hospital and sent him home
that they did better when they were away
from him
at home
on their farms
than when he had him in the hospital
and it finally dawned upon him that
exercise was the reason for it
thank you scott thank you too for acting
as a host
at the camp for us today
there's a girls camp the clara bottom
camp
that has a program just like ours
boy won't they flip when they find out
that you've been here and not there well
as a matter of fact i'm going over to
the parabotan camp tomorrow after the
dedication
are you always going to be at the
dedication you bet i wouldn't miss that
for anything me too
[Music]
we are met today
to celebrate the 250th anniversary of
the founding of oxford massachusetts
[Music]
in this city
were born two persons who achieved
distinction by their service
to humanity
clara martin born in oxford in 1821
she brought about the formation of the
united states branch of international
red cross
dr elliot p johnson born here in 1869
became professional medicine a
distinguished physician
known the world over for his teachings
and diabetes but my real privilege today
is the introduction of dr charles h best
thank you dr root i enjoyed every time
i ever met
dr elliot p joslin
and i am delighted to have this
opportunity to pay a
tribute to his memory
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr best many of us knew dr jocelyn
rather well too
and your speech at oxford really meant a
lot to us some of the things you said
were just the way we felt about him
thank you susie dr johnson knew how to
say things
wonderfully well
i've enjoyed having the tour of the tara
barton camp with you three girls and i'm
amazed at how many things you've learned
to do well
we've been wondering just what did
happen to the children in the days
before insulin what was it like well
kathy there were
thousands of years
after diabetes was discovered
when there wasn't much you could do for
children
you fed them as little as possible and
they they lived for a time
then in 1921
and 22 when we had insulin
the first children did very well
but we didn't have much insulin
and with one or two of the children we
ran out of insulin and we lost the
little
girls one little girl and one boy
you know dr beth that dr jocelyn took
care of my mother
in fact he warned her that i'd that i'd
have a good chance of becoming a
diabetic
yes we know uh
susie that
diabetes does run in families and it
passes down from the mother or the
father to some of the children
uh
linda someone told me that you've been
in the camp here for
seven summers you'd come for seven
sundays yes i've been coming to claire
barton for seven summers now and what do
your uh parents think about your coming
do you think they
they're very pleased have you learned
something that gives them
satisfaction
yes they're pleased that i've come to
camp because by coming to camp i've
learned to take care of myself by
adjusting my diet and my insulin taking
the right amount of exercise and so i
can control my diabetes by myself which
puts them at ease because when i go away
from home they won't have to worry about
me
well i think you're right
linda
this is a wonderful camp
i've been at a lot of other camps
and uh
after thinking about them i feel that
they do a great deal not only for the
children but for the parents
girls dr jocelyn was very much
interested in these diabetic camps too
he used to talk about them when i saw
him in boston
and i remember he mentioned them when he
came to toronto to see the opening of
our
research
institute
dr johnson was interested in uh
investigation of research
and he was interested in the camps
and he told us at that time that he
hoped someday he'd have a wonderful
clinic
where he could do all the many things
that he had in his mind to do for
diabetics
well as you know that clinic really has
come into being
and i
hope to go there again tomorrow
to predict the future
diabetic
hope to erect in boston a hospital
teaching clinic in which ambulatory
diabetics
can return at much less than regular
hospital costs
fully a third less
received instruction
encouragement
and such development of character
that life and health
unrecorded for diabetics
will be attained
[Music]
it's nearly 10 years ago now since dr
josem came to toronto
to take part in the opening of the
institute which they named after me
two years later
the cornerstone of this joseon clinic
was delayed
and here we are now
in the
completed
clinic
which dr johnson had so much desire
yes dr best
this clinic has fulfilled not only
the ideals which he expressed
there found in your institute but also
the hopes which you know he had as long
ago as 1922 when you first came to
boston and here are the
opportunities for training patients
an adequate and proper diet is more
important today than in the treatment of
diabetes than ever before
and here we emphasize the doctors
teaching patients how to measure and
evaluate
food
when a child develops diabetes it helps
tremendously if the child and her mother
can together in the same room be
treated and the mother learn
firsthand the best methods
for the care that child
perhaps the most important single thing
for a diabetic patient to learn is how
to test the urine for sugar and when to
do it
important aspect of our program is a
doctor's teaching of patients
mr cohen you have known
the teaching and training in diabetes
over many years which dr jocelyn
inculcated may i ask you
how you feel about it
when i first came here 25 years ago with
my daughter
who is then a child diabetic and myself
i was worried alarmed tortured how i was
going to care for both herself and
myself
after being a week at the clinic
in the teaching unit i learned how to
take care of us i learned all about diet
and food exercise the care of the
insulin to such a great degree that i
was completely in confidence i had the
absolute confidence that i could go home
and take care of all my problems my
fears were gone and i felt that i could
do all that was necessary for the best
of both of us
can you have diabetes without having any
apparent symptoms
why yes of course
very early in diabetes sometimes there
are no symptoms and you have to find
elevated blood sugars or urine sugars
is it necessary to keep insulin in the
refrigerator the insulin you are storing
should be kept in the refrigerator but
the insulin that you are using can be
kept at room temperature
if one member of a family has diabetes
should the other members of the same
family be checked
why certainly
diabetes has hereditary tendencies and
other members of family should be
checked particularly those who are
overweight if any
these pills sound exciting can all
diabetics use these pills
no i'm afraid not while many of the
diabetics who are milder get by with the
pills perfectly well
most diabetics and certainly more severe
ones still require insulin
we all agree that one of the most
important things in looking after
diabetics
is to teach them
i know that this has done extremely well
in the clinic here i've seen
dr joslin
you howard and many others
giving a great deal of their time to
patient education
dr rood i know that dr jocelyn has been
interested for many many years in
training physicians in the various
aspects of diabetes and that they've
come to him from all over the world
yes and today we have a group of doctors
from many countries in various types of
training
in fact they have a number of questions
to ask you dr best
i always wondered dr best how you happen
to find insulin and many other
researchers have failed
i suppose there's a an element of good
fortune in all successful research
we had
several assets really
we had a
good surgery fred banting was a an
excellent surgeon
and then we had the
micro methods for doing blood sugar
which all our predecessors had had
lacked
and then we had uh
youth we weren't too much concerned
about what had happened before we
started
dr best you have a long-range picture of
the diabetes mellitus problem could you
tell us what advances you hope will be
made for the diabetic patient in the
next 10 years
well of course no one can be completely
certain
about
any
research problem about the solution of
any research problem until it's actually
accomplished
but i think the indications are that we
will have synthetic insulin
it won't be any different perhaps in
potency than the natural insulin
but we're going to need someday more
insulin than you can make from natural
sources
i think we all like to be interested dr
west to know how you went about getting
the first insulin and also getting
enough of it
well our first insulin was made from dog
pancreas it was very good material but
of course you can't collect a lot of
pancreas from dogs
then we went to
beef pancreas
and this proved to be an excellent
source we had to change the technique of
extraction a bit use different strengths
of alcohol and
acid and so on
but the main problem at that time was to
get into large-scale production
we did some of the preliminary work
in the university of toronto
but we were fortunate to have the
cooperation of one of the great family
companies
in the united states the eli lilly
company
and their engineers were expert
in doing the sort of thing that needed
to be done
i remember that i went there nine times
in the first year
try to tell them what i knew and
they taught us a very great deal
and i think the insulin committee of the
university of toronto
was very happy that we
selected the
eli lilly company to work with us for
the first
preliminary
difficult
year in the large-scale production of
insulin
dr best
in your travel around the world do you
find the society of lay people
are developing programs in the field of
diabetes well dr jocelyn and i had the
honor of being the first
honorary president of the international
diabetes federation
and over the years i've been in a great
many countries where
societies
devoted to the interests of diabetics
have been formed
in some countries these societies are
doing a wonderful work
and uh in others of course it's it's
slow
but the idea of the international
diabetes federation
is to use the knowledge gained in the
more active countries
and to apply this
in the effort to help those
countries which are not so fortunate
dr lozano you're finishing your two
years here in the clinic
and you're going back to mexico
do you feel that you'll be able to apply
a lot of the new information which you
gained while you were here
yes i do i will work in the hospital of
nutrition disease where like many other
places in mexico we have a high standard
medicine
of course there are areas in latin
america as in other parts of the world
where getting enough food for the
children is the special problem
and finally now
his best hope is deepest hope a new
laboratory for research
one of dr johnson's most absorbing
interest in the last 20 years has been
the
study and prevention of blood vessel
disease dr reese you're conducting
research in this field tell us about it
our research has been directed at the
relationship between the control of
diabetes and the progression of small
blood vessel disease
studies to date clearly indicate that
good control retards the progression of
small blood vessel disease in diabetes
another aspect of our research focuses
upon the blood vessels of children
who have a high index of chance of
developing diabetes
with this camera
we can pick up abnormalities in the
blood vessel before there's any evidence
of diabetes by the usual clinical
criteria
i suppose uh doctor root that this
clinic has a a very
special meaning
for you personally you are dr jocelyn's
first associate
and i i believe that you gave the the
first dose of insulin that was
administered in in new england
yes charlie but let me say this even
before the discovery vincent dr johnson
had demonstrated that devotion to the
care of the patient that keen interests
in learning and in teaching
when
we learned
that you
and dr banting had each given yourselves
a dose of insulin although neither of
you had diabetes right
i should not have been so terrified as i
was on that day on august 7 1922
when there stood before me this frail
nurse with diabetes which had reduced
her weight from
pounds of 6 to 5 pounds
how much insulin should i give her
how much did you actually give her
actually charlie i gave her one unit
and my heart
beat yeah
and there
there she is the nurse
who learned to give instant she was then
the lovely miss peterson and now mrs
simons
mrs adams what do you remember of that
period in 1922
i
remember particularly the children
because they started to
grow and thrive and live happily
and in those next months
she was the nurse first instructed
to teach the administration of insulin
among the nurses yeah of the deaconess
hospital
dr elliot proctor josem
was one of the greatest men whom i've
ever known
i heard his name when i was seven years
old
i met him in toronto in 1922
and i was in very close touch with him
throughout the rest of his life
i'm sure that i speak for everyone who's
taken a part in making this record
we all feel highly honored and so
since 1922
with the discovery of insulin by doctors
banting and best and the leadership of
dr elliot p joslin in development of a
program of patient care
there has evolved a new life a normal
life
for millions of diabetics and their
families
i am
you